-Thanks to
newly developed technology
we here at "Late Night" --
we now have the ability
to record the tiny voice that is
inside Donald Trump's head
And you might be
surprised to know that,
like everyone's inner voice,
it's filled with
paralyzing fear and self-doubt
So, here is the tiny voice i
the back of Donald Trump's head.
♪♪♪♪
-Hey, Donald.
It's the tiny voice
in the back of your head.
And you've done it now.
You have to stand next to
a tiny, old woman
while she shows you
boring [bleep]
Oh, that's interesting.
Yeah, point.
That shows her that you actually
care about what she's saying
Now what is this?
Oh, my God.
Is she actually gonna show you
a photo album with pictures?
And you have to lean down an
pretend like you care?
Hey, remember, when you used t
go to the Playboy Mansion
and you used to
run Miss USA pageants
and you would think,
"This is so great
'cause I'm not with an old woman
showing me even older things"?
And you thought,
"I'm a winner, not a loser,"
and then you blew it all
by running for president?
Look at camera like a weirdo
There it is.
♪♪♪♪